[Música]
el ruido constante por debajo de tus
pies el espacio limitado y la monotonía
de ir a ninguna parte
parece que han pasado horas pero solo
han transcurrido 11 minutos y te
preguntas Por qué me estoy torturando
esta cosa debe considerarse un castigo
cruel e inusual
en realidad eso es exactamente lo que es
o era en el 1800 las cintas se crearon
para castigar a los prisioneros ingleses
por aquel entonces el sistema
penitenciario inglés era extremadamente
malo la ejecución y la deportación eran
a menudo los castigos empleados y los
prisioneros enfrentaban obras de soledad
en celdas inmundas
movimientos sociales liderados por
grupos religiosos organizaciones
filantrópicas y celebridades como
Charles dickens intentaron cambiar esas
condiciones para así ayudar a reformar a
los presos cuando alcanzaron el éxito se
remodelaron cárceles enteras y se
introdujeron nuevas formas de
rehabilitación como la cinta de correr
Así es como funcionaba la versión
original inventada en 1818 por sir
William cubet los prisioneros entraban
en 24 radios de una gran rueda de
paletas mientras la rueda giraba el
prisionero estaba obligado a mantener la
intensidad por el riesgo de caerse
Mientras tanto la rotación hacia mover
el engranaje para bombear agua moler
grano o mover molinos lo que originó el
nombre en inglés de
molino de pasos
esos dispositivos se veían como una
forma fantástica de azotar a los
prisioneros cuyo beneficio de accionar
molinos ayudaba a reconstruir una
economía diezmada por Las Guerras
napoleónicas
una victoria para todos menos los
prisioneros
se estima que en promedio los
prisioneros pasaban seis o más horas al
día en cintas de correr el equivalente a
subir entre 1500 y 4.000 metros
4.000 metros es más o menos la mitad del
Camino al monte Everest Imagínese así
cinco días a la semana comiendo poco
la idea se extendió rápidamente por el
Imperio británico y Estados Unidos en
una década más de 50 prisiones inglesas
usaban una cinta de correr y en Estados
Unidos una cantidad similar el ejercicio
combinado con una mala nutrición hizo
que muchos reclusos sufrieran colapsos y
lesiones lo que a los guardias no
parecía importarles
en 1824 El guardia de la prisión de
Nueva York James Hardy decía del
dispositivo que la firmeza monótona y no
su gravedad es lo que conforma el terror
una cita con la que muchos Todavía están
de acuerdo
las cintas caminadoras perduraron en
Inglaterra hasta el siglo XIX hasta que
fueron prohibidas en virtud de la ley de
la prisión de 1898 pero el dispositivo
de tortura volvió como una venganza esta
vez dirigido al público desprevenido
en 1911 se registró una patente para una
cinta de correr en los Estados Unidos y
en 1952 se creó el precursor de la cinta
actual
cuando la locura de correr llegó a los
Estados Unidos en la década de 1970 la
cinta volvió a ser protagonista como una
manera fácil y cómoda para mejorar la
capacidad aeróbica y perder kilos no
deseados Y la máquina ha mantenido su
popularidad desde entonces
la próxima vez que se someta a lo que
fue una vez un castigo cruel e inusual
alégrese de poder controlar subir y
bajar de él
la caminadora no es el único producto
cotidiano que tiene un pasado
sorprendentemente oscuro y cruel rastree
la historia no tan dulce del chocolate
hasta sus raíces en Mesoamérica con este
video
[Música]